if you're looking for a database  management system you can't go wrong  with mongodb actually I was gonna say  MySQL my SQL like like yours personally  well my is not a pronoun  it's the name of one of the developers  daughters what's with [ __ ] anyway it's  short for humongous as in mongodb can  store humongous amounts of data well  MySQL can handle large amounts of data  too as part of a foundation of web  applications mongodb represents data as  Json documents which is great for  document oriented databases whereas  MySQL enforces a schema gotcha the  document-centric approach makes mongodb  ideal for Content Management systems and  high query sites such as analytics apps  so the best database management system  is dependent on how you're going to use  it but you've got to admit mongodb is a  humongously better name